Tommy Lee Bobby I'm glad to see you my
friend last time I saw you we used to
well remember that period of our lives
where we ate up we ate a lot of Italian
food we Tatas we know there was that
Italian restaurant in Detroit oh yeah
that one we went crazy on Italian food
so T and I T and I at we've done a
couple of things together we were when
we were in Detroit we did that movie
Harold and I wish I could remember the
name hair.look Kumar Christmas people
the Christmas PAF corona commerce
Christmas people yeah Christmas people
and I don't that was fun
you were the bravest I've been in a lot
of movies that's not a brag that's some
of them and one or two good movies
you had the hardest day I've ever seen
anybody put up with on that movie
there's a scene where Bobby if you guys
seen the picture yeah yeah
there's a scene where Bobby gets pelted
with eggs you're running from Mike Lee
yeah and they shot that so many times
and it was like it was a machine yeah
yeah like a tommy gun egg machine
shooting at you
each egg it's like having a paintball I
believe in the script that said it looks
like the shot of Charlie Sheen in Pluto
right yeah and what happened was you're
a real channel I they go it's gonna
sting but you can handle it I got ya
dude it's [ __ ] nope no breather hit me
yeah it was the most painful thing I've
ever felt by the way also like can you
get like Legionnaires disease from just
like murder you yeah you know what the
director did too he goes there's not
enough on the face his own eggs
yeah and just started throwing eggs on
my head when I'm on the ground
yep though the bastard I remember
thinking I remember thinking this is
[ __ ] up yeah and I should say
something
did you [ __ ] no cuz I was like what if
they come for me right I was like when
they come for Bobby that's a good time
for me to stay low and be like I don't
know him I don't know him and you know I
also know with you on John save the
world I know that's when you got me to
start smoking again cuz you made it look
sexy you were smoking and I was just
looking at you you got to be very
careful cuz I was out looking at you and
you we were sitting on a break on the
universe a lot and I used to smoke three
packs a day one time I smoked cigarettes
through my nose I've had my wisdom teeth
pulled
yeah guys like don't you dare smoke I'm
like alright so I'm like [ __ ]
when I left a cigarette so I was that
guy yeah then I quit for a long time
yeah and then I saw you and then you're
just sitting here's what you're doing
you're literally just like lounging
outside right now funny really yeah
and then I bummed a cigarette off you
and they even smoke and then I was like
hey can i one more later and then like
later I chased your car and I would give
me one more I'm gonna murder you yeah
and then then it does smoke for a couple
oh my god I'm great I'm just so sorry I
look back it was you you just made it
appealing and I when I never see you
never said like dude is Robert I'll kill
you right matches give me you wanna let
you just did just look cool yeah smoke
anymore no I know we talked about that
before before we even started here now
exact over here over here oh yeah it's
been over here I know alright because
I'm suffering through it when I was
working on that show yes Sean Hayes and
it was a sitcom oh my god funny on that
no but can I just say something
uh-huh I literally like and I
I I like white dudes I do I think the
real nervous oh there's one between me
and the door I mean what I'm saying I
don't really kind of tiki torch looking
dude between me and the door I didn't
say that
I mean you present I can't help you
behind
I'm just it's not me yeah how do you
present for the way you presented yeah
let's be real okay so yes I saw but we
said was I love what no I know but I do
but what I'm saying is is that I get
like when I see some comics and stuff
and the Caucasian I go yeah I got to
defeat them or I can be bad or wrong bad
right or whatever right just one of
those things where it's it's the way
that I can like own up to my ethnicity
and and find courage and you know and
and and set marks for myself but when I
saw you on that show I'm not and I know
you don't probably don't like
compliments but do so [ __ ] if someone
warned in advance or like hey whatever
you do don't call our song no [ __ ]
good dude
thank you I'm good I'm really good in
small doses which is why you love dog
days not currently oh you want to segue
into the thing you're most quick already
yeah I'm gonna get and we're not there
no we're not talking about it well I'm
doing I'm gonna thing is I'm just gonna
do that like 16 times and yeah yeah
but now I'll segue right days it's an
out dog dance right now and when did it
Friday came out yeah uh Wednesday but
you know you know Ken Marino from the
state yeah the big the handsome Italian
yeah yeah I love them
yes Ken directed it Wow yeah so it's a
little funnier than you might expect
right and it's a it's is there obviously
dogs in it
there's nothing but dogs in there I saw
the poster yes
Tom Bell was told I love Tom yeah I saw
the poster yeah yeah the post out days
cuts off it's always yeah so are you any
of those legs I'm the on the the the
khakis you are as you can tell by the
incredible bulbs oh yeah again he's
looking at me now so the dog is is out
saw the movie obvious you love it it's
very funny movie
yeah it's a sweet movie now there's
sometimes there's movies that like my
in-laws in ohio don't want to see that
I'm in right that's most of my over you
know yeah is either you know like a bad
teacher like just my wieners on the
Xerox machine stupids happening but this
is the one there's actually like a fun
movie that like people can go see great
and they won't hate you later yeah well
we love dogs and I I do I always have
three fact we have a picture of our dog
in front of one of the you know those
the bench Oh cute wait will you have a
photo of one of our dogs in front of his
dog days poster oh you do yes well
that's amazing with one of the dogs
Julio is the sort of salt and pepper a
little little Brown crazy would you have
dogs I got two dogs Heidi and Pedro
[Music]